I couldn't miss the opportunity
to put two great environmental minds, head to head
in an earth day trivia showdown.
(audience applauding)
Here's how it works.
We'll play these three rounds
based on the three R's of earth day,
reduce, recycle, and reuse.
Now each correct answer is worth one point.
I'm excited to introduce our next evolution of trophies.
It's the earth day trophy.
(inspiring music playing)
It's beautiful.
And if Neil deGrasse Tyson thinks it's beautiful--
It's already engraved with his name.
(everyone laughing)
Okay to raise the stakes
Danny has brought some special gifts for our VFF's.
Danny, if you will.
If I win you're all gonna get
this beautiful Olivia Burton watch.
We love Olivia Burton.
It's a British brand that really took off in England.
It's now over here.
It's all inspired by nature and the stars.
And astronomy.
That's beautiful.
And it has a vegan straps,
a really beautiful $145 I believe for the watch.
But here's what you're really getting.
Cause when Neil wins, you're gonna get a prize
from my favorite website to shop at.
It's Olive and Cocoa.
And Olive and Cocoa, they use these beautiful wood crates
that are reusable
full of healthy, earth friendly, fun edible gift, succulents
There's so many things.
When you can't find the perfect gift,
go to Olive and Cocoa and you will all get a hundred--
Uh uh, I'm so nervous.
They're all gonna get a hundred dollar gift card
to Olive and Cocoa so--
Yay!
Why did I agree to do this?
Okay, here we go round one.
Reduce.
(upbeat music playing)
Question, 200 million pounds of this
is thrown away every year
and it doesn't break down naturally very easily.
It is, you wanna try?
Chewing gum.
Okay Danny now get nervous.
All right, here we go.
Oh sorry what?
And okay here's the solution
to reduce the amount of chewing gum that you chew
try chewing on organic mints or a sprig of parsley.
Okay question, is it vital
that we reduce the amount of plastic going into our oceans.
Which ocean has the largest accumulation of plastic?
I think that was a charity wait.
I'm gonna say Pacific.
This is known as the area
of the great Pacific garbage patch.
And if you want to see on our globe
this is literally where it is.
And one thing that we can all do to reduce ocean plastic
is to participate in beach cleanups
or simply pick up trash on the ground when we see it.
By the way, the Pacific ocean, because it's so large
that's where we drop satellites
that we don't use anymore.
Really?
They fall out of space and they go--
So Skylab is in the Pacific ocean.
Yeah, that's the big toilet bowl for space debris.
Oh, I hate that the ocean is a toilet bowl.
Okay next round.
Reuse.
(upbeat music playing)
A great way to reuse food is to compost,
but which of the following is not recommended for composting
dryer lint, hair and fur or fish bones?
Danny seemed to get that buzzer.
Threw a loophole.
I'm gonna go with dryer lint
because it depends on the type of detergent you use.
And no.
Oh.
(everyone laughing)
And if you dry synthetic fibers that are in the lint
so they're not technically compostable,
go to Twitter.
Okay.
Neil your turn.
I was gonna say dryer lint too.
Yeah.
Okay
you guys guess what?
It is none of that.
It is fish bones.
Fish bones and other animal bones
take long, very long time to break down.
Dryer lint is carbon rich and will decompose easily.
And surprisingly hair and fur contains tons of nitrogen
perfect for the healthy compost pile.
Okay go to the bonus Sex and the City question.
Okay.
(everyone laughing)
Meanwhile,
I got it.
On planet earth, I had to wonder.
Okay, reuse.
Which of these plastic containers should not be reused?
This salad container, this soup container
or this pad Thai container?
None of them should be reused.
Neil?
I would say the pad Thai container.
Neither of you are correct.
And I don't mean that belittlingly or patronizingly
It's the salad container, not reusable.
It's made of plastic one, which is safe for single use
but it is not a good idea to reuse
because it has that porous surface, that traps bacteria.
All right, final round, recycle.
(upbeat music playing)
(audience applauding)
Which one of these items is not recyclable
the wet cereal box, magazines--
Magazines.
Danny?
(buzzer sounds)
A wet cereal box, magazines, a used pizza box.
Pizza box.
(buzzer sounds)
It is pizza box.
Pizza box?
Yes.
So how come I can recycle other sort of corrugated boxes
and not have a pizza box?
That's a good question.
Well Neil, astrophysicist from Danny Seo lifestyle expert
I will tell you that because of the grease and cheese
that's absorbed by cardboard pizza box,
that makes it non-recyclable.
And not only shouldn't you recycle it
but it can contaminate an entire load of recyclables
by trying to do it.
(audience cheering)
But if it didn't have the grease and cheese in it?
You can.
I have to say that my body responds like a recycling bin.
It does not recycle pizza.
Awesome.
Okay which of these holiday items is recyclable
plastic Easter grass, Christmas lights--
Holiday lights.
You are correct.
Congratulations to our earth day trivia champion showdown.
It is Danny Seo.
(audience cheering)
This is the best birthday gift ever.
And VFF's, not only did Danny win,
but you guys are the biggest winners of them all
because you get both gifts.
(audience cheering)
Now--
I wanna be a VFF so I can get presents.
I know I feel the same way.
I'm totally greedy right now, I'm like I want everything too
it's been such an honor to do this with you today.
And Cosmic Queries is available now in bookstores.
It includes literature, writing, tweets.
It really breaks it down
in a way that I think every generation can truly respond to.
Thank you so much.
Congrats, Danny.
Yay.
(upbeat music playing)